[Musique]
bonjour à tous comme tous les jours à la
même heure c'est l'heure du thé et deux
points de vue merci d'être avec nous
pour ce rendez vous en direct sur figaro
live quatre sujets qu'on va découvrir en
images tout de suite
l'évasion de redoine faïd spectaculaire
par hélicoptère ce délinquant condamné
pour un braquage raté et entraîné la
mort d'une policière municipale cette
évasion continue de faire des vagues
nicole belloubet la garde des sceaux est
elle responsable doit elle démissionner
on se posera la question
on parlera aussi de la seine saint denis
14 élus de ce département envoie une
lettre de détresse au premier ministre
c'est le figaro qui le révélera demain
dans son édition quotidienne mais dont
on vous parle dès ce soir
la seine saint denis est elle abandonnée
et l fichu compte tenu de la gravité de
la situation on se posera la question
on va parler aussi de biodiversité à
l'instant même
nicolas hulot le ministre d'état chargé
du ce de l'écologie et donc de la de
diversité propose un plan ambitieux un
de plus qu'est ce qu'on peut faire on te
demanderas nos invités et ses yeux il
était ministre
quelles mesures prendre et il pour ce
sujet qui nous concerne tous paix dans
tout le monde se fout pas en tout cas
c'est ce que dit nicolas hulot c'est pas
moi et puis nous parlerons de la fronde
des élus locaux
en tout cas de leur association qui
refusent de se rendre à la conférence
nationale des territoires organisé par
le premier ministre ont-ils raison de se
plaindre ou écrit-il avant d'avoir mal
vous nous donnerez votre point de vue
bonsoir mathieu soupière ravis de vous
accueillir vous êtes membre associé de
la fondation jean jaurès vers un ancien
conseiller de myriam el khomri ministre
du travail du quinquennat d'hollande qui
a donné son nom à la loi
bien connue sagana ziari bonsoir vous
êtes journaliste analyste en politiques
publiques vous êtes un collaborateur de
l'iref think tank libéral vous
définissiez comme un peu comme un
libéral libertaire on peut dit ça on
peut dire ça comme ça libère un
classique j'aime bien libéral classique
presque comme jacques de guillebon mais
pas tout à fait quand même
pas du tout dit il je vous taquine est
car je m'en doutais vous êtes le
directeur de la rédaction de la correcte
site internet et magazine dans lequel
s'expriment toutes les tendances de la
droite votre dernier numéro nous met en
couverture un magnifique coq et ses
titres et ses français qui ont fait la
france et puis caméus et là aussi bon
soir karl ravis de vous accueillir vous
êtes le rédacteur en chef politique du
figaro magazine
votre dernier livre françois hollande le
président du temps perdu on est un peu
dans la nostalgie ce soit a été publié
aux éditions stock
voilà on parle on reparle de l'évasion
de redoine faïd cette évasion elle date
de dimanche mais on a appris grâce au
figaro d'ailleurs que l'administration
pénitentiaire avait demandé le transfert
de ce délinquant qui avait déjà et qui
s'était déjà évadé
sauf que ça s'est perdu dans les arcanes
administratives et l'administration
centrale a dit pas avant septembre
donc de toute évidence il ya des
dysfonctionnements est ce que la
ministre de la justice doit en tirer les
enseignements et démissionner c'est la
question que notre consoeur elizabeth
martichoux lui a posé ce matin sur rtl
et voici sa réponse non pas du tout je
pense que je pense que c'est vraiment
pas le bon moment
nous sommes face à une situation qui est
grave je crois qu'une évasion hors norme
comme celle qui s'est produit c'est un
événement grave il faut réagir non pas
avec des postures comme je peux
l'entendre parfois mais au contraire
avec calme et avec fermeté
mais tu soutiens vous avez été
collaborateur de la ministre
à quel moment est ce que un responsable
gouvernemental est responsable de ce qui
se passe dans sa sphère de compétence
responsable au point de devoir
démissionner s'il ya eu un
dysfonctionnement il est déjà
responsable quand ils ne surent réagit
pas à l'actualité
et quand il ne mène pas une politique du
fait divers celle qu'on avait été
habituée en particulier sous le mandat
de nicolas sarkozy à avoir chaque jour
dès que l'actualité produisait un fait
divers une réaction politique qui se
voulait d'envergure majeure avec
éventuellement même un texte de loi
soumis au parlement dans les 15 jours et
on voit bien qu'en fait tout cela
permettait d' agiter d'amuser la galerie
mais en aucun cas de produire de
l'efficacité en matière de politique
publique et alors là moi je ne sais pas
évidemment d'avis sur le sujet la
ministre à l'âme et la ministre la
ministre a pris la pris la décision
qu'il fallait prendre qui consiste à
lancer une inspection pour faire la
lumière sur toutes les défaillances
éventuelles du système
je note juste que healy à 65 milles ou à
peu près des prix en france je crois et
que le nombre d'évasions de ce type est
évidemment même pas résidé à la
marginale par définition c'est un
événement exceptionnel extraordinaire
qui sort de l'ordinaire et donc je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il faille derrière
penser le système pénitentiaire en
fonction de ce que révèle un événement
comme celui-ci qui ne me paraît pas être
représentatifs
ensuite évidemment tout doit être pris
toutes les mesures doivent être prises
pour garantir la sécurité des personnels
voit ça on est tous d'accord là dessus
je crois ce point de vue et consensuelle
alors cette émission est la vôtre vous
vous exprimez évidemment sur les réseaux
sociaux sur lefigaro.fr sur twitter
jusqu'à présent vous êtes plutôt
favorable à une démission de nicole
belloubet c'est ce que nous dit chantal
une incarcération daniel ou encore
jacqueline nom richard sur lefigaro.fr
nous dit dans le fond c'est le personnel
pénitencier qui va devoir assumer les
conséquences de cette évasion
jacques de guillebon votre point de vue
sur ce sujet nicole belloubet doit-elle
démissionner non moi je pense pas j'ai
pas de sympathie particulière pour elle
mais c'est pas parce qu'un détenu
s'évade
mais dans des conditions rocambolesques
comme celle ci qu un garde des sceaux
doit démissionner je pense que c'est un
peu absurde
en revanche un vrai problème dans le
système pénitentiaire convient de
remettre au goût du jour si vous riez
dans cette prison là de réaux je crois
que vous avez trois son gardien pour 450
ou 500 prisonniers longue peine donc
c'est quand même pu y avoir des relais
entre les détentions ultraman et
apprennent beaucoup c'est rien donc on
se pose la question de pourquoi ça a pu
se passer alors qu'il ya tant de
gardiens que ça et puis après voilà on
sait qu'il ya une surpopulation
carcérale de merlin je crois que c'est
70 me de même qu'on a aujourd'hui de
deux personnes incarcérées pour 50000
places après le ministre a lancé comme
toujours un plan de création de places
de prison
on attend de voir que parce que ça
arrivera si ça arrive un jour
mais là en l'occurrence je crois pas que
ce soit de sa responsabilité ou de son
fait cette évasion est ce que c'est
aussi votre avis ferghana y arrive pas
pour qu'on puisse parler de faits divers
quand on a une évasion aussi
spectaculaire que celle ci alors je ne
sais pas si madame des loupés doit
démissionner en revanche effectivement
elle à la tête de l'administration
pénitentiaire donc à doit rendre des
comptes
inévitablement moi j'aurais aimé que le
parlement se saisisse tait depuis cette
question parce qu'on a effectivement
missionné un corps d'inspection pour
établir les responsabilités voire les
dysfonctionnements entre les services
déconcentrés de l'état et
l'administration centrale
c'est aussi je crois le rôle du
parlement de surveiller l'administration
et donc les organes du gouvernement voir
quel est le responsable s'il ya un
responsable de cette défaillance et le
sanctionner c'est un haut fonctionnaire
un responsable politique ou la ministre
dans ce cas là il faut mener l enquête
car mais finalement qu'est ce qui pousse
un ministre à devoir démissionner
c'est sa responsabilité objectif pousser
la pression médiatique et politique
c'est de plus en plus la pression
médiatique
on est bien loin de l'époque vous
souvenez alors c'était pour d'autres
circonstances d'un jean pierre
chevènement qui dit un ministre ça ferme
sa gueule ou ça démissionne et lui il
avait enchaîné les démissions plus quoi
faire
à peu près dans chaque gouvernement mais
la grippe et il a fini par partir mais
plus pour des raisons de deux accords de
fond il traite que de bourde ou deux
voilà une faute comme le carreau si là
il était pas mise justice donc il
n'aurait pas eu ce cas là à traiter mais
où est ce que je fais est intéressant
c'est dans ce qu'elle dit ce matin parce
que elle dit c'est pas le moment de
démissionner
c'est pas ça l'argument en réalité
quelle heure est il utilisé puisque
c'est pas la bonne raison voilà ce que
vous avez tous visiteurs elle va pas de
démissionner dès qu'il y en a un qui
prend la poudre d'escampette parce que
je pense qu'à ce moment là on a eu
beaucoup de misère justice qui aurait dû
démissionner a commencé je sais pas ce
que vous souvenez par christiane taubira
qui le jour où elle a été nommée il y
avait c'était pas du tout sont fait de
leur côté les mises à jour et organiser
un match de basket et il m'a fait une
partie qui était cadré profité pour
pourtant % mais c'était d'arriver que
l'acquis mathieu nous dit avec une
ironie mais assez intéressante si une
enseigne d'une chaîne de magasins se
fait braquer le pdg de cette chaîne
doit-il démissionner donc effectivement
ça pose le sujet de la responsabilité
directe il ya un point connexes qui a
été abordé par jacques de guillebon
c'est le nombre de places de prison qui
de vous qui doivent être construites
emmanuel macron avait dit pendant la
campagne présidentielle qu'il voulait
construire quinze mille puis finalement
ça risque d'être beaucoup moins comme le
rappelle un peu perfidement mais c'est
normal
le député républicain des alpes
maritimes eric ciotti où sont les places
qui devait être construite par monsieur
macron on nous annonce et 15000 places
sur le quinquennat c'est aujourd'hui
7000 rien n'est fait la garde des sceaux
venu dans mon département elle a
supprimé la construction d'une place de
prise d'une prison à saint laurent du
var
la réalité elle est là y'a pas le
courage de se donner les moyens dans une
grande loi de programmation que le sujet
n'est pas madame double jeu personnifie
pas le problème jeudi que le
gouvernement globalement n'a pas pris la
mesure de ces enjeux
est ce qu'on peut dire avec déguisements
que ce gouvernement est un peu mal à
l'aise quand on est sur le sujet de la
répression on ne sache pas l'impression
que ça fait quand même assez peu de
temps qu'ils sont au pouvoir donc on
peut pas savoir combien de
places de prison y construirons je ne
suis pas sûr que sous le sarkozysme
n'est construit beaucoup aussi
je sais plus mais enfin bref monsieur
doivent être assez proche du poids à
cette époque eva et puis après c'est son
c'est son fond de commerce de toute
façon les places de prison non je n'ai
pas l'impression enfin par rapport aux
gouvernements précédents qui lui est
très peur de la répression je trouve
qu'on est plus dans un rééquilibrage est
un peu plus de de courage à mon avis que
de manière précédente
vous êtes indulgent mathieu soupière non
mais c'est cher en comparaison en fait
en matière de taux d'incarcération et je
renvoie aux travaux notamment de
l'observatoire entre 1,6 md prison et
entourent matière de taux d'intérêt
l'incarcération pardon la france a
longtemps était en dessous de la moyenne
européenne
pas très loin en dessous mais en dessous
de la moyenne européenne depuis les
politiques qui ont été menées depuis une
quinzaine d'années grosso modo non
seulement la france a rattrapé son
retard mais la france a un taux
d'incarcération supérieure à la moyenne
on met plus en prison en france que chez
les pays voisins quand je crois que
madame taubira avait cassé la peine
plancher et cetera qui fait que des gens
peuvent rester jusqu'au ils sont
condamnés à deux ans de prison reste en
liberté
il n'empêche que et et même si
effectivement un certain nombre de
partis politiques en fait
philosophiquement pousse des peines de
substitution et ida il n'empêche
qu'aujourd'hui en fait on n'a jamais
autant incarcérés en france aujourd'hui
et il ya même une forme de consensus
droite et gauche ce qui est quand même
assez assez savoureux alors qu'en fait
le 50e anniversaire de mai 68 il ya
aujourd'hui un consensus pour en fait
construire toujours davantage de places
de prison
or les études démontrent aussi que plus
on construit des places de prison
plus on incarcère des gens en fait c'est
une tautologie mais derrière la justice
elle même
sachant que à elle a des places l année
lit comme on dirait à l'hôpital elle
condamne à la prison des gens qui en
réalité pourraient bénéficier entre
guillemets de peine différente et on a
aussi en france
un chiffre qui fait réfléchir on a 30 %
des détenus qui sont en fait en
détention provisoire et la surpopulation
carcérale elle tient beaucoup passent la
part parce que 30% de détention
provisoire pour le coup c'est très
supérieur à ce qu'est la moyenne
européenne qui est de 20% est donc là il
ya probablement matière à réflexion on
développe très peu les travaux d'intérêt
général qui avait été lancé par robert
badinter il ya déjà longtemps mais que
le gouvernement macron a dit vouloir
d'une façon ou d'une autre
faire revivre ces prolos une piste
intéressante tant en matière de pop et
de gestion de la population carcérale
que de réintégration des détenus
qu'il sorte car c'est probablement la
question essentielle en fait que celle
de leur réintégration une fois qu'ils ne
sont plus en prison quand mes choix je
crois que les chiffres donnés par eric
ciotti ont été confirmés parlent par la
garde des sceaux s'était en fait par
rapport au nombre de places de prison
prévue il se construira la moitié
s'étaient on avait 10 15 milles sera
plutôt 7000 et pourtant il n'ya pas
vraiment de 2,2 d'attac sur le
gouvernement là dessus c'est pas c'est
pas un angle de critique de l'opposition
une forme de laxisme comme on l'a dit
beaucoup pour christiane taubira encore
elle parce que ce sont des problèmes
budgétaires très simple c'est à dire que
effectivement on peut dire comme de
gaulle sauté sur l'europe comme un cabri
et dire construire des places de prison
c'est bien c'est bien sauf qu'à un
moment il faut faire le coût de ces de
cette construction
et si vous dites d'un côté il faut
désendetter l'état respecté les clips
budgétaire et mais de l'autre côté vous
dites il faut construire des prisons
il ya un moment où il faut faire un
équilibre ce qui est intéressant dans la
stratégie des républicains c'est qu'il
n'appelle plus à la démission de
ministres comme il avait pu le faire je
pas si vous vous souvenez à l'époque
sous jean françois copé s'était à chaque
fois qu'ils avaient un peu un problème
on ne t'oubliera démission est au fond
ils ont vu la limite de l'exercice c'est
à dire que certes on se fait plaisir et
on fait plaisir peut-être à une partie
de l'électorat mais d'un autre côté de
toute façon la personne ne va pas
démissionner et ne sera pas poussé à la
démission par le président ni le premier
ministre est donc ça montre une sorte de
d'impasse de l'opposition est donc là
dessus il ya des leçons qui ont été
tirés par wauquiez et par eric ciotti on
ne demande plus vous avez fait plus
admis nativement demande plaidé me alors
que marine le pen est la démission quand
il ajouté nicole belloubet sakana
diaries est ce que la solution c'est la
construction de prisons privées où il ya
eu des phases ya eu des des dents mais
il ya eu des initiatives de ce type en
france où un garde des sceaux il ya
quelques années déjà maintenant c'est
vrai mais charles donc dans un travail
aux etats unis en australie ou
on délègue au secteur privé la
construction de prisons mais je voudrais
rebondir
un instant sur la question budgétaire
parce que je trouve que la question
budgétaire elle n'est pas suffisamment
mis en avant et surtout elle pose la
question on a vite dû de la nécessité de
recentrer l'action de l'état c'est à
dire aujourd'hui on est dans un pays qui
dépense donc 57% donc il ya une dépense
publique qui s'élève à 57 % du pib
donc cela pose la question de la
rationalisation de la dépense publique
est-ce qu'on privilégie un état qui
vient dépensent davantage dans la
redistribution la protection sociale ou
est-ce qu'on se concentre davantage sur
les missions essentielles du monopole de
la de la force qui définit l'état à
savoir les fonctions régaliennes la
police la justice l'armée et quand on
voit à quel point les fonctions
régaliennes aujourd'hui sont délaissés
par rapport à d'autres missions de
service public type qui pourrait être l
don délégué au secteur privé sans
interroge à mon avis la nécessité de
rationaliser davantage et denis public
quelques points de vue d'internautes
toute façon faut payer un jeu quel que
soit le gestuel jeu qu'elle est de toute
façon il faut payer mais l'aja pays avec
57% dépenses publiques on peut se
demander s'il n'y a pas quelques même
quelques postes en cela va être
en cela les les français sont pétris de
contradiction puisque certes on veut
limiter la dépense publique et on se
répète depuis des années qu en france la
dépense publique est trop élevé mais on
veut effectivement construire plus de
prisons mais on veut effectivement des
hôpitaux qui accueillent plus qui
accueille mieux qu'ils soignent mieux et
c'est à nos parents on veut des écoles
qui accueillent nos enfants en leur
prodiguant le meilleur service public de
l'éducation possible et je me permets
juste quelque chose là dessus c'est
assez intéressant
la fondation jean jaurès que j'ai
l'honneur de représenter aujourd'hui a
publié il ya quelques semaines une étude
sur les attentes de français vis-à-vis
du monde pénitentiaire en fait c est
cette enquête révélée quelque chose de
tout à fait troublant est intéressant
les français ont pleinement conscience
du fait que le système pénitentiaire
aujourd'hui offrent des conditions
d'accueil aux prisonniers relativement
indigne et ça ne les choque pas c'est à
dire que la privation de liberté d'une
part et des conditions de détention
relativement hostile ça fait partie en
fait de la peine et il ya deux points de
vue là dans l'opinion en fait quelque
chose qui s'est durci sur 50 ans et
rennes est la privation de liberté celle
les mots qui aujourd'hui est déterminant
aux yeux des français là où autrefois la
réinsertion des détenus
une fois leur peine purgée était la
priorité voilà ce qui choque c'est quand
on apprend qu'il y avait des portables
dans que ryan ryan fin il avait un
portable et qu'on a un autre détenu qui
lui a pu filmer et diffuser sur les
réseaux sociaux
l'évasion parce qu'on voit jamais dans
ce sont les images qu'on est en train de
vous projeter quelques points de vue
d'internautes lolo sur lefigaro.fr la
ministre n' est pas à la hauteur de
l'enjeu
il y à un dysfonctionnement entre
l'administration et nicole belloubet et
maxime il le dit la question et que
fait-elle avec son ami collomb le
ministre de l'intérieur pour que les
choses s'arrangent
et les internautes sont du figaro sont
assez partagés sur ce sujet puisque
c'est la question du jour sur le
figaro.fr
et il ya une majorité réelle mais quand
même assez courte puisque ses 52% qui
considère que madame belloubet n'a pas à
démissionner on passe à un autre sujet
le figaro de demain révélera mais nous
le faisons en avant première une lettre
envoyée le 14 juin dernier par des
parlementaires de tous bords à
l'exception de ceux de la république en
marche des parlementaires élus de
seine-saint-denis au premier ministre
pour se plaindre de l'abandon dans
lequel l heure leur département ils
décrivent une situation assez terrible
avec un très grand nombre de d'immigrés
clandestins avec des difficultés
sociales avec un taux de chômage très
élevé avec des problèmes culturels du
fait d'une forte immigration et
d'enfants de l'immigration tout à fait
tout à fait légale celle là écoutez ce
que disait philippe dallier il est
sénateur les républicains de
seine-saint-denis c'était il ya quelques
jours au talk du figaro
et ça fait un moment qu'il y a le feu en
seine-saint-denis et en seine saint
denis on ne parle plus de quartier dans
une commune
on parle d'un département à l'échelle de
combien il ya probablement deux millions
d'habitants seine-saint-denis c'est à
dire trois ou quatre oui il ya dix ans
un préfet m'avait dit ça ya à peu près
300 millions des saints dans le
département nos collègues députés qui
ont rendu le rapport 10 entre deux et
quatre cent mille
l'état n'est même pas capable de savoir
combien il ya d'habitants dans ce
département
ces regards nasillard et la situation
est tellement détériorées quand on se
demande même si ce département il est
pas entre guillemets fichiers c'est à
dire que si l'action publique ne peut
plus rien faire aujourd'hui je ne serais
pas aussi pessimistes pensent qu'il ya
plusieurs problèmes à identifier quels
problèmes d'une part donc de la pauvreté
donc du chômage donc c'est le problème
social problèmes économiques et ça alors
je vais peut-être fait pas vraiment vous
surprendre c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
la problématique de développement
économique qui intéresse la
seine-saint-denis elle est analogue aux
problèmes nationaux à savoir pourrie
lieu le chômage il faut prendre les
mesures pour à savoir on le sait ouvrir
le marché du travail cela n'a pas été
suffisamment fait on est ici dans un
département où la proportion de
population faiblement qualifiés est très
élevé par rapport à la moyenne nationale
ça implique donc des réponses beaucoup
plus ambitieuse que ce qui a été fait
jusqu'à maintenant avec les ordonnances
de monsieur macron l'année et l'année
dernière et sur le volet sécuritaire
mais je pense qu'on est face à un autre
problème c'est à dire que on accuse
beaucoup le trafic de drogue d'être au
centre effectivement de tous les
problèmes de criminalité
ce qui est vrai mais on n'interroge pas
les facteurs institutionnels qui rendent
ces trafics aujourd'hui dangereuse qui
font que les criminels les organismes
criminels monopolise le commerce des
drogues est la solution qui a été
adoptée dans plusieurs pays dans le
monde notamment aux états unis pour
neutraliser des cartels neutraliser du
groupe mafieux c'est la ligue édition du
commerce légal pour justement ôter à ces
cartels le monopole du commerce du
cannabis notamment mais on de toit
d'autres pays vous savez un pays comme
le portugal n'a pas dépénaliser la
production et la consommation de toutes
les drogues qui ont été dépénalisées
pour ce pays là vous savez c'est un
économiste libéral à milton friedman qui
disait quand vous regardez la guerre
contre les drogues finalement d'un point
de vue économique c'est protéger le
cartel s'est finalement aux fruits un
monopole au cartel et au criminel
je pense que plutôt que de déverser
toujours plus d'argent public pour le
ticket veines pour une guerre qu'on ne
gagnera jamais il est temps de se poser
la question de la rationalisation là
encore de la politique criminelle
et de désengorger les forces de l'ordre
des tribunaux pour les concentrer sur
des missions pour les affecter sur des
missions beaucoup plus utile plus que de
pourchasser des industries qui ça ne
peut pas être éradiquée en fait jacques
de vivant non mais je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec la propagande de l'iref
qui veut enlever l'état partout vous
enlever toute façon le sida mais dans ce
que l'on fait quoi en fait on laisse le
trafic d'armes pour tout le monde ou du
trafic d'organes c'était donc c'est pas
il n'y a pas que le trafic de drogue qui
est dedans fennell précédent gvt états
unis sur on a toujours ces mêmes
discours la hausse des revenus pour de
la première moitié du 20e siècle quand
on a créé médiane quand on a criminalisé
le commerce d'alcool on est honnête des
cartels du groupe hilton a même avoué
c'est toujours la même temps peu commune
à prohiber les phénomènes les phénomènes
ti les phénomènes le phénomène site qui
permet de favoriser l'émergence de
groupes issus criminelle est le même ici
quand vous ne réalisez une industrie
vous conférer des monopoles des dix
groupes criminels cécile ces précisions
je sais plus où on en était mais bref
non mais c'est pas ma phrase de cocteau
puisque ces mystères demeurent fait d'en
être l'organisateur en fait c'est donc
voilà une fois et si on a dit ça on a
tout réglé un oui je pense mais on peut
agir à partir du moment où on coupe où
on détourne les flux en fait parce que
les flux de ce sont tous les maires de
seine-saint-denis qui vous le dise
appartement ils ont assimilé des gens il
ya un an qu'ils sont il ya les flux qui
arrive tout le temps donc ils peuvent
recommencer tout le temps des flux
d'immigration légale ou clandestine et
ils doivent tout le temps recommencer
remettre sur le travail d'un métier et
il n'arrive jamais en fait tu sois maire
de montfermeil xavier lemoine qui est un
grand ami qui me l'expliquer donkey il
pense avoir réussi et il doit
recommencer encore et parce que tous les
flux d'immigration arrive là-bas enfin
principalement à cause des aéroports et
puis parce que après les des communautés
dont on en sait ce à ses montées les
unes les autres
donc c'est ça ce serait une solution
c'est à dire de détourner les femmes de
les stocker en partie déjà pour les flux
de clandestins et même pour
l'immigration légale je pense qu'il
faudrait diminuer et ensuite essayer de
les répartir ailleurs enfin de les faire
aller ailleurs ce que sinon c'est
impossible en fait c'est vraiment une
un travail de pénélope celui de sisyphe
en fait mathis cas on atteint là les
limites du vivre ensemble dans ce
département
en tout cas c'est oui c'est une
problématique majeure je vais faire un
peu de maquereaux et je vais être
d'accord un peu avec mon voisin de
gauche et un peu avec mon voisin d'en
face il est vrai de dire que la seine
saint denis en particulier évidemment et
est un concentré de difficultés
économiques et sociales auxquelles
s'ajoutent des questions liées à
l'immigration puisque j'ai fait exprès
migration qui laisserait ses problèmes
économiques et sociaux
et alors en fait il ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui et les populations de ces
territoires là il y à quelques décennies
était française de souche comme l'on dit
fbt pauvres c'était des populations des
catégories ouvrières
il se trouve que comme vous le disiez à
l'instant en fait on a sans doute bien
fait de mettre beaucoup d'argent dans
ces quartiers parce qu'en fait on a
permis quand même assez quartier de
survivre d'une part ceux qui continuent
à dire on a injecté de l'argent à fonds
perdus et en fait ça n'a réglé aucun
problème il est faux ça il est faux de
dire ça a permis à ces quartiers de
vivre et ça a permis aux populations
populaire d'autrefois pour certaines
d'entre elles d'accéder à une forme de
mobilité sociale et géographique et de
quitter ses quartiers et comme le disait
jacques à l'instant effectivement à
chaque fois ces populations sont
remplacés par d'autres populations
nouvelles misérable parfois venons de
l'étranger donc avec les difficultés
d'insertion qui s'oppose quand on ne
maîtrise pas la langue bien en revanche
pour qu'il faut arrêter l'immigration
en revanche il est vrai que non là pour
le coup je rejoins je rejoins ce que
disait mon camarade d'en face on sait
aujourd'hui qu'une des mesures à prendre
qui n'a rien d'irresponsable pour casser
ce qui pose pour les banlieues serait
comme l'ont fait certains pays très
raisonnable de légaliser effectivement
la drogue on a c'était une des vertus
d'une des vertus pédagogiques du rapport
borloo que le dire il y a dans ces
quartiers-là cinq cent mille jeunes qui
viennent le mur
cinq cent mille jeunes qu'il ya par
ailleurs des études qui disent deux cent
cinquante mille personnes vivent du
trafic de la drogue
je ne dis pas que ce sont les mêmes mais
tout le monde sait qu'il ya un recroise
mans un croisement de ces chiffres un
recouvrement de ces chiffres et que donc
les murs sont ceux qui n'ont pas de
travail et que des officiels exactement
déclaré
or certains on le sait vivre de ce
trafic par annoncer qu'ils ont et donc
sam a en tout cas à partir du moment où
encore une fois on casse cette économie
parallèle
je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui mais ça
n'est pas un désengagement de l'état ça
ne constitue pas un désengagement
la réalisation des moyens je suis
entourée d' acte est acté la réalité
telle qu'elle sera toujours comment
toutes les drogues et déjà les pdg ont
légalisé le cannabis ou hôtes n'ont pas
fait sur la base d'arguments d'un qui
relèverait d'un hédonisme libertaire
c'est un argument sécuritaire avant tout
l'été des préoccupations sécuritaires
qui ont conduit des populations
demandent aux autres on n'en peut plus
donc faites quelque chose
arrêtez de d'entretien toute une
industrie manière hypocrite dans la
clandestinité ce qui génère toutes les
difficultés que l'on connaît quelques
points de vue d'internautes
arnaud claudie ne doit-on pas raser et
reconstruire ces quartiers et y mettre
plus de mixité culturelle point
d'interrogation
lolo nous dit il ya un problème culturel
mais l'état ne veut pas l'admettre jorat
nous dit il faut un quotas d'immigration
et s'y tenir et la gauche c'est
peut-être un pseudonyme jusqu il suit
modèle social moins d'immigration et
plus de police c'est la seule solution
carmat us cet appel au secours des
parlementaires de seine-saint-denis
c'est un peu une réponse à l'enterrement
du plan borloo parle aux pressions de la
république
oui ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
l'origine des parlementaires parce qu'il
y en a certains qui viennent de la
france insoumise
on sait qu'ils sont assez nombreux à
avoir été élu en 2007 il y a un à deux
villes hôtes un alexis corbière un
marie-george buffet que le communiste
gué communistes il ya jean christophe
lagarde de lui dit on a entendu un
membre des hells
ils ont dit on voit qu'ils sont d'accord
sur le constat je doute qu'il soit
d'accord sur les réponses
il ya certains noms qui feint on voit
bien aussi ce qu'ils ont fait en matière
de communautarisme je suis pas sûr que
de clientélisme
exactement je ne vais pas sûr que ce
soit la réponse qu'attendent un certain
nombre de parlementaires des
républicains après ce qui peut et non
des noms les aurait reconnu après ce qui
peut c'était pas forcément la solution
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir la réflexion qu'un conte un certain
nombre de deux candidats notamment
potentiel à la mairie de paris et dans
la réflexion que cahill manuel macron
sur le grand paris et que ce soit chez
les républicains ou chez esi de la
république en marche il pense à
fusionner les trois départements
limitrophes de paris hauts-de-seine
seine-saint-denis et val-de-marne deux
avec paris dans le faire elle s'appelait
la scène en fait reprendre cet ancien
département
ça ne règle aurait peut-être pas tous
les problèmes et du coup on dirait pas
la seine saint denis mais au fond ça ne
concerne pas c'est un autre endroit
c'est un no man's land c'est loin de
chez nous non ça serait le même
département et peut-être que du coup on
y mettrait plus de moyens parce que ça
concernerait les gens qui se verrait
appartenir au même schéma et on y
réintroduire est peut-être davantage de
mixité sociale puisque on sait quand
même que ces effets de ghettos sont très
difficiles derrière à gérer mais ensuite
c'est très compliqué il se trouve que
j'ai j'ai un dossier très épais j'ai
travaillé avec myriam el khomri certes
mais j'ai aussi travaillé à la mairie de
paris du temps de monsieur delanoë et on
y avait une politique très offensive en
matière de logement et logement social
qui visait notamment à rééquilibrer les
choses au plan territorial
quand on voit comment aujourd'hui encore
il est très compliqué en fait de mener
une opération immobilière d'installation
logements sociaux dans le 16e
arrondissement où vous avez du jour au
lendemain
dès que le projet émerge en fait une
levée de boucliers de riverains de
voisins etc qui ne veulent surtout pas
que la porte de la muette où la porte de
saint-cloud havre de paix soit pollué
entre guillemets par l'arrivée de
personnes qu'on juge absolument
infréquentable et dont on dit qu'elles
ne pourront jamais s'intégrer à la porte
de la muette parce que le daily monop en
bas et beaucoup trop cher donc c'est
très très compliqué en fait d'installer
l'idée que notre dessein collectif c'est
précisément d'aller vers davantage de
mixité sociale pour avoir une vie
vie collective un peu plus douce quand
on va là discret la description qui est
fait de la vie en seine-saint-denis
compris par ses élus on peut comprendre
peut-être les réticences de gens qui
disent on va voir arriver des
populations qui ne sont pas assimilés
qui pose des difficultés spécifiques par
exemple à l'école passe quand vous avez
trop d'enfants qui maîtrise mal le
français
c'est peut-être pas uniquement du
racisme ou du snobisme mais parce qu'on
seine-saint-denis il y à 0 mixité
sociale
il ya zéro mixité sociale en
seine-saint-denis il ya zéro mixité
sociale à la porte de la muette
vous avez al'inverse des villes ou des
quartiers où la mixité existe la mixité
vie elle n'est pas synonyme de tirer les
enfants vers le bas à l'école elle n'est
pas synonyme de chômage de masse elle
n'est pas synonyme d'insécurité une fois
sam québécois après je sais pas ce que
vous appelez mixité sociale en
l'occurrence mes électeurs me cissé qui
concerne le logement la loi voilà médias
les curieux mais vous savez des
logements sociaux à paris qui sont de
grands immeubles dans lequel on entasse
les mêmes populations faites les vous
recréez le même calme et me dit tout et
bien on trouve totalement d'accord et
ben c'est la politique de delanoë en
fait non pas du tout à l'égout longe
l'avenue jean moulin des exemples assez
proche en fait et ça se passe comme ça
je suis prêt à discuter précisément vous
en parlera très gros c'est une
méconnaissance du dossier
il ya des propositions qui sont faites
par les besoins de cette lettre le
figaro en parle demain
qui dit si on veut identifier où sont
ces ghettos lutter efficacement contre
la discrimination
il faudrait faire des statistiques
ethniques est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est une bonne idée
question ouverte je rencontre les
statistiques ethniques après je ne vois
pas le rapport entre mixité sociale
pauvreté chômage c'est à dire que pour
moi ce sont des débats qui sont
complètement différents lorsqu'on voit
les signataires de la tribune donc gens
comme clémentine autain ou avec ses
gardiens très sceptique sur les
solutions que ces gens là vont vont
proposer c'est à dire que depuis des
décennies en france quand on est à ce
point de la pauvreté ou des difficultés
économiques on a toujours la même
solution à savoir acheter la paix
sociale avec toujours plus de subsides
et était à providence
or on sait que si on veut mener une
véritable de développer une véritable
politique de développement économique
il faut prendre le problème à la racine
et donc qu'est ce qui cause la pauvreté
qu'est ce qui fait que la
seine-saint-denis n'attire pas
suffisamment de capitaux pour élever le
niveau de vie des gens qu'est ce qui
fait que les populations n'arrivent pas
à s'insérer choix marché de l'emploi
donc il faut se poser les conditions l
est
institutionnels et tout ce qui relève
donc des politiques régionaux ter et
fiscal pour attirer de quoi créer de la
richesse sur le territoire pour moi la
question de la mixité sociale elle est
un autre débat
il est orthogonale à la question le
développement économique sans vous
parler de la france comme d'un pays du
tiers-monde en fait comme s'il fallait
que l'on crée un développement
économique qui n'existe pas évidemment
ce missane me séduit on n'a pas du tout
besoin de statistiques puisque on sait
que la majorité la population est
d'origine immigrée ou immigrés va donc
on s'en fiche de savoir de quelle ethnie
ils sont on sait qu'à une concentration
une population qui est culturellement
différente majoritairement et qui
étaient entassées là est la question
n'est pas de de créer une politique
économique qui n'auraient jamais été
créés en seine saint denis c'est lui
c'est uniquement à mon avis l'arrivée de
cette population en masse en fait qui
fait qu'on peut pas l'intégrer sur le
marché du travail c'est pas parce que
marcher le travail seraient trop fermées
qu'il faudrait l'ouvrier en fait on a
interdit l'amour notre très facilement
intégrer des tas de vagues migratoires
dans le monde du travail à certaines
époques donc je crois pas qu'ils aient
deux c'était pas aussi grosses que ça
ait pas aussi concentré mais alors jeu
pareil je pense que nous devrions
ensemble reprendre les chiffres de ce
que représentait qu'une certaine je vois
juste un mot important là un mois
important parce que je l'avais penserait
est très important de croiser cette
question de l'origine
et cette question du chômage et de la
pauvreté je me sens je ne pense pas du
tout comme vous que ce sont deux
questions disjointes bien au contraire
énormément d'études démontrent que il y
a dans ce pays de la discrimination de
la discrimination à l embauche de la
discrimination dans l'accès au logement
et à vis à vis de certaines populations
un incident qui s'appelle l'institut
montaigne qui se dit aussi think tank
libéral comme celui dont vous êtes issue
avait publié il ya quelques années une
étude démontrant que une personne ayant
un prénom à consonance maghrébine je
crois que c'était c'était ça le sujet
avait quatre fois moins de chance d'être
reçu un entretien d'embauché à formation
équivalente qu'un petit jacques mathieu
ou que sais-je
voyez donc je pense que ces deux
questions sont au contraire
malheureusement très imbriqué je pense
qu on en reparlera merci mathieu
soupière un dernier mot de lolo qui nous
dit il n'y a pas que la
seine-saint-denis venait dans les hautes
france et vous constaterez le désastre
on passe à un autre sujet
en ce moment même nicolas hulot le
ministre d'état chargé de l'écologie est
en train de présenter un grand plan pour
favoriser la biodiversité la
biodiversité c'est le fait que il ya
toutes les espèces possible alors
qu'elles sont en train de disparaître et
c'est pas seulement un problème de
rhinocéros blancs pour recadrer le sujet
de façon très concrète
écoutez ce que ce canton et ce matin
bruno david il était sur rmc et c'est le
président du muséum d'histoire naturelle
nous avons besoin de la biodiversité
nous ne sommes rien sans la biodiversité
en est un simple exemple nous abritons
deux kilos de bactéries sur notre corps
est dans nos intestins
sans ces bactéries nous sommes morts
donc on a besoin de la diversité on se
nourrit de la biodiversité on respire
grâce à la biodiversité
s'il ya plus de plancton dans l'océan il
ya moins d'oxygène
on respire plus donc voyez on a besoin
absolument de la biodiversité
il ya plein de mesures qui sont en train
d'être annoncée par nicolas hulot il ya
une possible augmentation du nombre de
réserves naturelles en france et les
mesures très concrètes
par exemple pour l'utilisation des
plastiques savait que les cotons-tiges
vont être interdits mais aussi peut-être
ce qu'on appelait tout y est pour
tourner son café mais aussi les pailles
en plastique on vous pose la question
d'ailleurs sur twitter est ce que vous
êtes prêt à abandonner le plastique est
pour l'instant vous ne répondez oui à
75%
bravo pour cet esprit civique et
écologistes sur le fond
carl meeus c'est un sujet très important
et en même temps nicolas hulot le
reconnaît lui-même tout le monde s'en
fout de moins en moins je trouve qu'il
est obligé de dire ça pour montrer que
voilà il faut que ces durées mais
heureusement il a exactement voilà
l'aspect politique mais je trouve qu'il
ya de plus en plus de prise de
conscience que
que les océans on parle tous de ce
continent de plastique dans les océans
de la biodiversité qui disparaît et donc
les gens
ont pris conscience de ça le problème
c'est que nicolas hulot il fait son plan
à l'échelle de la france c'est très bien
sauf qu'à l'échelle de la planète la
france suffira pas quand on voit les
images de ces fleuves dans les pays
d'amérique du sud qui déchire charrie
des tonnes de plastique qui ensuite vont
vers la mer malheureusement le plan
hulot il ne suffira pas feuillet quoi
vous à peine vu si vous deviez être en
charge d'un plan pour la biodiversité à
l'écouté j'ai vu l'autre jour un député
des yvelines michel viala qui proposait
de revenir au recyclage de supprimer les
bouteilles en plastique et de revenir au
recyclage des bouteilles comme on
faisait comme faisait nos parents la
consigne pardon des bouteilles et
éliminer toutes les bouteilles en
plastique le problème c'est que ces
économies quand c'est compliqué à mettre
en place il ya beaucoup d'entreprises
qui vivent de ça ben oui mathieu
soupière faites quoi vous pour la
biodiversité des ours y compris dans le
9e arrondissement de paris pourquoi
uniquement dans les pyrénées non non je
alors monsieur je n'ai pas dit est très
précise la cet instant précis mais dont
je vous le dis c'est sur ce que disait
carl meeus
non on peut penser hier on peut penser
global et agir local y compris sur ces
questions alors je j'enlève ma casquette
fondation jean jaurès
j'ai été dans une vie antérieure aussi
directeur d'une entreprise publique qui
faisait de la gestion de la production
et la distribution d'eau à paris et
alors c'est très intéressant mais donc
un témoignage il y à quelques décennies
locon consommer au robinet à paris elle
venait de source située à 150 km en eure
et loir en vo regagne etc elle était
naturellement potable le schéma
d'alimentation en eau aujourd'hui il a
été mis en place par le baron haussmann
à l'époque il était déjà très écolo en
fait ce schéma d'alimentation
aujourd'hui l'eau de source qui vient de
ces zones que je précisais à l'instant
cette eau de source
elle est plus du tout potable évidemment
et la rendre potable ça coûte quasiment
aussi cher que de potabiliser de lot de
scènes et de l'eau de marne ce que la
moitié de l'eau consommée à paris lé
pont elle est coupée dans la seine dans
la marne moitié aux deux nappes moitié
eau souterraine moitié eau de rivière
est donc aujourd'hui
lot 2
l'eau de source elle est aussi polluée
quasiment que l'eau de rivière pourquoi
parce que cinquante ans de politique
agricole commune de politique un goal
extensive de politiques agricoles
polluantes
or si on allait vers une agriculture un
tout petit peu plus bio beaucoup plus
respectueuse de l'environnement on
n'aurait pas ces pollutions notamment
des nappes souterraines et donc en fait
on règlerait une partie du problème
à notre échelle voilà parce qu'en fait
le problème il doit se régler ici et
maintenant chez nous aussi
alors si on est tout seul ça a moins de
poids mais en tout cas nous mêmes on a
nos responsabilités à assumer
jacques de guillebon c'est les sujets
qui intéressent la correcte vous êtes
leur présence d'une forme de droite
écologistes on pourrait dire ça oui mais
je pense que toute la droite devrait
être écologiste de manière naturelle ou
ce campus est plutôt de ce côté là que
l'écologie est né et à l'idéologie
conran ans bien avant
non chez les mêmes terres neuves annaba
rien à voir je vais chercher les non
conformités années 30 des gens comme
jacques ellul et ses gammes sous de
lauriers lire dans l'armée elles ont
foncé c'est ça dont je me réclame un
women ilitch par exemple aussi mais
moins chaud plutôt elle me presque
décroissant en fait voilà mais si je
drague on immigration non en tout en
fait foi la mort que ça va ensemble en
fait cesser totalement c'est tellement
logique c'est ce qu'on appelle les
limites les frontières etc
en fait voilà c'est ça pleurait beaucoup
moins en fait
si si je vous assure et concrètement on
va faire sur les deux tiers nord le
terme en jeu permettront le jeu fort
soit tous les viticulteurs à faire du
vin naturel par exemple parce que j'aime
beaucoup ça et ça ferait du bien non
mais je le rejoins que l'om était tous
qu'il fait du bon boulot
je pense qu'il pourrait faire du
meilleur boulot et notamment sur les
questions dit qu'ils faisaient et cetera
je pense qu'il est il a un peu brouillé
qui pour avoir un peu plus de de courage
en fait sachant d'où il est en plus
chaque année avec votre point de vue sur
ce dossier de la biodiversité alors une
biodiversité c'est un terme qu'on entend
tout le temps mais je suis fait quelques
recherches personne ne sait comment
définir en fait la diversité c'est à
dire que on annonce des plans avec une
ambition cavale de révolutionner la
nature la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui
quand vous parlez à des athées
spécialiste en biologie
ils sont incapables de vous définir les
contours idéaux de ce que devrait être
une biodiversité un environnement idéal
donc on est là dans quelque chose qui
est complètement arbitraire
la réalité c'est que la notion de
biodiversité donc de contour idéal c'est
la relève d'une construction sociale ces
clauses du cahier très subjectif qui
dépend des cultures qui dépend de
l'appréciation individuelle et qu'il est
vain comme ça d'arrivée du haut de son
administration et dire moi je veux faire
latter vous pensez qu'on exagère le
problème on exagère alors le problème je
sais pas s'il ya des soucis avec des
extinctions d'espèces mais ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'on peut pas
remédier au sur 7
je possède peut pas arriver comme ça
d'où son administration il dira je vais
révolte et la biodiversité la
biodiversité en tant que tel avec un
grand b ça n'existe pas c'est à dire
qu'il ya des de diversité il ya des
environnements ya des écosystèmes et la
question est dans la nature de la
qualité de la qualité d'un environnement
de l' équilibre est un et
et un est un débat qui qui comment dire
relève de l'appréciation subjective de
deux chacun et qu'on peut pas arriver en
disant mais la diversité phoques était
un défenseur talentueux du libéralisme
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour dire
que on peut pas laisser les gens faire
tout ce qu'ils veulent par exemple les
agriculteurs utilisaient des produits
qui augmentent le rendement mais qui
peuvent être mauvais pour la planète
d'un point de vue libéral la question
environnementale elle se règle sur la
question de la responsabilité
individuelle c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui une d1 des principales
problèmes liés à l'environnement c'est
qu'on est très souvent confrontés à des
tragédies du bien commun parce que les
ressources sont mal gérées parce
qu'elles sont collectiviser parce qu'il
n'y a pas de droit de propriété a signé
sur telle ou telle parcelle qui fait que
les individus ne sont pas incités à
prendre soin de ce qui ne leur
appartient pas donc il y à une solution
qui qui est qui et quand on veut dire
qui est théorisée par de nombreux
économistes qui consiste à dire ma pour
notamment protéger l'environnement les
ressources les animaux les espèces en
voie de disparition
une solution serait de mettre en place
des mécanismes institutionnels relatifs
à des droits de propriété pour inciter
les gens à conserver ce qui doit être
conservé tout en ayant bien à l'esprit
qu'encore une fois les contours idéaux
de la biodiversité ne peuvent pas être
déterminer objectivement nicolas compris
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui disent on va
rater à dire tout bétonisation pour
protéger quelques espèces dans ça
n'importe quoi quelques mots laissés à
nos chers internautes
lolo décidément très actif aujourd'hui
qui nous dit supprimer le plastique
c'est bien mais qu'en est il des
voitures électriques et des batteries
et tandis que la gauche ne dit la prise
de conscience doit la prise de
conscience par don doit être mondiale
n'y at il pas une différence de
consommation entre l'europe l'asie et
l'afrique
on revient à paris d'un mail pour un
petit mot de politique on disait que
nicolas hulot était pas très ravie au
gouvernement vous pensez qu'il est en
train de faire ses valises
on en est où là parce que d'une semaine
à l'autre qu'on a l'impression qu'il a
des états d'âme
différents widgets rue des ponts
d'arbitrage qui peut gagner nicolas
hulot c'est pas un politique comme les
autres ce matin dans le parisien il est
quand même assez claire à la question
est-ce que vous prendrez des vacances
cet été il dit les vacances ça se prend
l'été mais moi c'est pas avant cinq ans
donc a priori il a changé d'avis par
rapport à ce qu'il avait dit il ya un
mois en disant je verrai cet été si je
suis encore utile et a priori la de ce
matin il dit je suis là encore cinq ans
on verra sur 1 sur 1 le cac est la
suivante puisque à priori on a pu poule
4 avec donc c'est une information qui
restera après macro même si le ballon
est alors il n'était pas ministre c'est
un homme de consensus
les élus locaux le sont un peu moins
consensuel en tout cas les représentants
des associations
vous savez l'association des maires de
france mais aussi celle des présidents
de départements ou de régions
ils étaient conviés à une conférence
nationale des territoires organisé par
le premier ministre pour parler
notamment des relations entre l'état et
les collectivités locales et ils ont dit
qu'il n'irait pas ils sont pas contents
écouter hervé morin hervé morin c'est le
président de la région normandie est
aussi le président de l'association des
régions de france
on a besoin d'innover l'état est
incapable d'innover
oui on a besoin d'agilité l'état est
incapable de pouvoir le faire on a
besoin de proximité dans l'exercice du
pouvoir et non pas de systèmes centraux
au bout du compte
oui qu'il y a l'incapacité de nous
écouter il ya le faux semblants de la
discussion
le faux semblant du dialogue alors on
vous pose la question sur twitter les
élus locaux at il raison de se plaindre
donc voila vous réagissez pour l'instant
la réponse est plutôt oui c'est même de
l'ordre de deux tiers/un tiers
est-ce que c'est aussi votre point de
vue carl meeus ou bien est-ce qui écrit
avant d'avoir mal les élus locaux écrit
avant d'avoir mal et de devoir augmenter
les impôts locaux
parce qu'il ne leur a pas échappé qu'en
2020 et en 2021 ils vont tous devoir
être renouvelée donc
ça leur fait mal surtout ce qui leur
fait mal c'est c'est que ça arrive à un
moment où on a appris que la dette de
l'état la dette continue à augmenter et
donc l'état n'avait pas diminué l'an son
endettement et qu'au fond ils on avait
l'impression ces collectivités locales
d'être ceux à qui on en perd en ont
serré la vis dans l'état continue à
dépenser ce qui est amusant de voir
c'est que au fond dans les trois
institutions qui est là il était assis
macro compatible la mf les départements
et les régions voilà dominique bussereau
quand emmanuel macron arrive au pouvoir
il est plutôt dans un très bon état
d'esprit d'ailleurs il quitte les
républicains il est président de
l'assemblée des départements de france
département des départements des
départements hervé morin est un peu plus
critique vis-à-vis des mails macro mais
enfin c'est quelqu'un quand même les
régions voire dans les régions et les
centristes c'est quand même quelqu'un
avec qui normalement maniema cruise
pourrait travailler et françois baroin
certes il s'est opposé à un meilleur
macro moment des législatives mais il a
pris du recul et c'est quelqu'un qui est
très consensuel ces trois personnes là
au bout d'un an de gestion des macros
ils en sont à lire ce n'est plus
possible
jacques de guillebon votre point de vue
sur ce sujet en ajoutant un point
intéressant c'est johan qui nous disent
ah oui ils ont raison
macron effarouchement parisien prenez
l'exemple des 80 km heure
oui bon on est 80 km heure je sais pas
si c'est la question la plus
passionnante
en l'occurrence mais évidemment ça fait
30 ans qu'on fait des fausses
décentralisation
qu'on leur impose des charges sans leur
donner les moyens de subvenir à ses
charges que la disparition de la taxe
d'habitation mais les maires dans une
situation impossible
mais dans cette force extrêmement c'est
paris c'est compensé mais c'est à dire
que ces îles sont plus maîtres en fait
de l'heure de leur fiscalité locale et
et voilà ça ça fait 40 ans qu'on fait et
je pense que ces trois personnes que
vous avez cités si elle était elle-même
macron compatible ans derrière elle
quand même je suppose quelques milliers
d'élus qui ne sont pas contents en fait
les pousse à aller se plaindre au
gouvernement et mac ronde a donné pour
l'instant aucun signe d'amour dé ce
qu'on appelle les territoires en fins et
voilà les endroits soient ruraux soit
des petites villes soit des confins de
la france en fait et je pense qu'il va
dans mon avis le payer s'il change pas
sa politique là dessus je vous soumets
ce commentaire d'internaute
ils n'ont qu'à limiter leurs dépenses
ils ce sont les élus locaux et donc à
limiter leurs dépenses inutiles
il y en a un paquet alors je suis
content quand même de voir ce sursaut
girondin dans un pays qui habituellement
optique est habitué à un jacobinisme qui
je crois paralyse un peu notre notre
pays c'est vrai que aujourd'hui et
maniema qu'on est dans un processus de
centralisation donc fiscal réglementaire
politique et que cela se fait au
détriment de la subsidiarité
or en france on a longtemps sous-estimé
justement le rôle de la solidarité et de
la décentralisation pour garantir la
qualité d'un régime politique quand on
regarde d'autres pays en europe la
suisse l'allemagne ou haute ce sont des
pays qui sont généralement un peu mieux
gérées qui avait payé fédéraux cpi il
fait des heureux tout à fait où il
existe une plus grande proximité des
centres de décisions vis-à-vis des
citoyens et donc on se rend compte que
finalement tout ceci à accroît la
qualité de ces régimes là on se serait
peut-être bien qu'en france on s'inspire
de ses modèles à condition aussi de
responsabiliser les élus effectivement
parce qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas à la
fois donc demandé plus de
responsabilités plus d'autonomie fiscale
sans remettre aussi en question des
mécanismes comme les péréquations qui
parfois tendent à à déresponsabiliser
un léger les collectivités les moins
vertueuses au détriment de ceux de
celles qui sont mieux gérées donc il y
en a bien un gros travail à faire de ce
côté là tu ce cas c'est un jacobin
emmanuel macron en tout cas faudrait
démontrer en fait les vertus comparer du
système fédéral belge ou italiens ou
suppose ils sont tellement plus efficace
ils sont des suppositions plus
décentralisée claude infiniment et je
sais pas s'ils sont tellement plus
efficace que nous en tout cas le trio le
trio morin c'est pour le trio morin
baroin et bussereau
si une tribune dans laquelle
effectivement ils dénoncent le pouvoir
technocratique et centralisateur de
jupiter qui se trouve ne pas avoir été
élue locale allant parfois peut-être
être élu local avant d'être président de
la république au ministre ça peut servir
alors malgré tout edouard philippe a été
député-maire et il y a deux poids lourds
soit disant dans l'équipe de macron que
sont gérard collomb qui s'occupe des
territoires en tant que ministre de
l'intérieur et jacques mézard sénateurs
en tant qu'union et il se trouve que les
deux manifestement ont du mal à rallier
les représentants des territoires à
maquereau à jupiter ce qu'il faut
effectivement la question me semble-t-il
de la politique territoriale du
gouvernement qui est un véritable
impensé je pense que macron à bien
penser la question économique
on est d'accord on n'est pas d'accord
mais en tout cas il avait pensé la
question économique
il a pensé la question internationale il
a pensé un certain nombre de questions
mais la question territoriale
indissociables me semble-t-il de la
question sociale est un impensé total de
sa politique et donc pour le territoire
qui fait pas on voudrait bien pensée et
bien je vous renvoie à une excellente
autre note de la fondation jean jaurès
dont l'auteur et jean viard qui
effectivement porte une politique
descriptif des territoires et qui
démontre bien que healy a en fait trois
territoires
il ya les métropoles qui sont très
imbriqué dans la mondialisation qui en
france pèse quasiment les deux tiers du
pib
ce sont les premiers de cordée que
macron apprécié tout particulier qui le
lui rendent bien puisqu'il ya une vote
pour lui en général mais donc il ya les
métropoles il ya les banlieues et il ya
la ruralité et la ruralité qui bien
souvent ressent un
éprouve un sentiment d'abandon très
grand à 20 kilomètres d'une gare donc la
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
refait société en reliant ces métropoles
ses banlieues totalement oublié
aujourd'hui plan borloo ça fait
totalement koshita lors des annonces
sont attendus pour juillet mais enfin
pour l'instant on est saisi de voir que
le plan borloo n'a rien donné alors même
que macron était celui qui contre valls
il ya deux ans parler des racines
sociales du terrorisme et donc
sous-entendant qu'il fallait agir
socialement dans ces territoires là et
la ruralité et donc la question c'est
comment est ce que en fait on relie ces
trois territoires pour redonner une
vraie dynamique collective
comment est ce que les habitants des
banlieues ont un droit d'accès à la
métropole à la culture de la métropole
comment est ce que les habitants des
territoires ruraux ont un accès à la
mobilité
toutes ces choses contre la culture
aussi bien sûr car mais on va donner un
scoop mondial pour les internautes qui
suivent point de vue dans le prochain
baromètre du figaro magazine qui paraît
vendredi emmanuel macron comme son
premier ministre ailleurs baisse de
façon assez substantiel on peut dire est
ce que c'est aussi à cause de cette
accusation qui revient quand même
régulièrement d'un pouvoir trop parisien
qui s'intéresse pas au territoire donc
hyper motivés de six points ce qui veut
dire qu'ils arrivera dans la zone un peu
dangereuse des 30 32 36% d'opinions
favorables ce qui est ça ne va pas leur
plaire notamment emmanuel macron le
rapproche dangereusement de françois
hollande à la même époque
ce qui est quand même assez savoureux
quand on sait que il a fait exprès de
prendre le contre-pied systématique de
françois hollande
mais voilà au bout d'un an ils en
arrivent un peu au même résultat
je pense que c'est une accumulation
c'est à dire que je parle sur le compte
sur votre contrôle mais quand on toutes
les études était fait les frais il ya
une grande partie des français qui
disait on va attendre de voir avant le
juge emmanuel macron il ya ceux qui
étaient résolument opposés ceux qui
étaient farouchement favorable et puis
une grande partie un marais disant on va
voir après tout on lui laisse sa chance
et là ça fait un an et au bout d'un an
au fond ils sont une grande partie qui
qui se disent ben non mais ça va pas le
compte y est pas le changement en quoi
il ya eu du changement dans ma vie c'est
plutôt négative vous avez eu quelques 80
km heure ça rejoint ce que vous dit
c'est à dire il faut peut-être lié les
trois territoires territoires ruraux
mais pour le coup les 93 80 km heure
c'est eux qui le paye plus que les
métropoles parce que toute façon en
métropole vous pouvez pas rouler à plus
de 30
et on mettrait encore plus de temps des
gens rejoindre la gare merci beaucoup à
tous les quatre on laisse le dernier
mois nos internautes à pattes qui nous
dit la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation sera remplacée par d'autres
taxes et arnaud qui nous dit tout est
géré de façon statistique par paris
c'est une technocratie voilà point de
vue c'est fini pour ce soir mais ça
revient demain même heure même endroit
merci beaucoup aux bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]